today I'm at the University of Sydney
with dr. Phil and we're talking about
the pressure that all of us are under
you are under a lot of pressure probably
ten thousand kilograms 10,000 kilograms
is pressing in on my whole body all from
all sorts where does all this pressure
come from
it's from the air that looks like a
dance moves I mean I don't know I'm
lifting 10,000 kilograms you're lifting
the air how much air is there above us
how about 20 kilometres or so so you're
at the bottom of an ocean of air so
essentially the weight of the air is
squishing me in that's right just I and
all of us you - and me - wow you seem to
be holding up rather well though thank
you thank you
how do you do it what it's not a special
trick uh-huh uh-huh I've got the same
amount of pressure inside me okay so
since the pressure is equal inside and
outside of you you're in equilibrium and
there's no sort of crushing or expansion
knot that's right okay well most people
I think don't recognize the pressure
that they're under yeah at least you the
atmosphere that's right how can we
demonstrate that the atmosphere is
exerting this huge pressure everyone the
best thing to do is to scoop out their
insides and then there'll be no pressure
on the inside and then they'll be
crushed by the atmosphere by the other
and that will be a rather clear
demonstration exactly of the power of
the atmosphere exactly but let's say we
didn't want to kill anyone
how can we demonstrate this in say a lab
well we could take a model of a person
and this drum is made to be a model of a
person that's correct yeah okay and then
so what are we gonna do with it so what
I want to do yeah go ahead we're gonna
put some water in here why don't we go
ahead and do it okay let's do it
get it heating up we've got some water
in the drum and we're heating it up on
this little gas stove here that's right
okay
and what is that doing for us so the
water will heat up and begin to boil so
it'll turn from liquid into a vapor that
vapor will push out some of the air okay
so basically we're going to remove the
air from inside the drum and replace it
with water vapor that's right okay okay
then once we're sure that it's pretty
much empty Devere we put the stopper in
mm-hmm and cool it back down again okay
so that's going to condense the water
vapor that's right and so what does that
do to the pressure inside the drum it'll
become much smaller okay and then we're
going to be able to see what the
atmosphere does when there's no pressure
on the inside which we've shown exactly
all right well I'll look forward to that
all right so how long do we have to wait
for this to boil and get all sorted ah a
couple of minutes mm-hmm we do a little
time lapse effect let's do that all
right
okay looks like we're boiling away
furiously here that's pretty good so
it's about time to perform the
experiment let's do it I bet it might be
a bit dramatic so I'm going to check on
a bit of gear safety glasses always
important yeah
and safety gloves to avoid burning your
hands on this very hot drum that's right
now you might want to gonna put those on
I will you might want to stand back a
bit because it's a little bit dramatic
what happens alright let's do it
all right so that water's turning back
into water vapor oh thank you
that's what you look like with 3000
girlfriends on your head 10,000
kilograms on your whole body you know I
was expecting I was expecting the
crumpled like slowly over time I wasn't
expecting it to just go all in once yeah
well cause it's circular a little bit of
it goes and the whole lot goes wow
they're quite thick quite strong for a
while yeah that was awesome
yep you can hear the air is trying to
get back in and now the pressure is you
equalize this key inside nice it's now
realized that's right wow that's one
hell of an experiment certainly is looks
like you wet yourself that was so
exciting that's partly true